hello and welcome to my talk why the new
v8 is so damn fast
so the entire a compiler pipeline was
totally overhauled by the VA team and
with the latest newest version v8
version eight kind of confusing actually
this new compiler Parker busy is really
smooth no no so it's very relevant to
understand what changed you know the v8
team tells us that we can now pretty
much like any JavaScript it's gonna be
fast is that true and so on I wanted to
kind of investigate so this is what this
talk is about
my name is soren Lawrence I work for
note source and he work remotely so this
would be a typical office this was in
Costa Rica beginning of this year where
I was working with like you know really
or not which was awesome and that's
actually where it took like about a
month to read about a v8 in in blog post
at the VA team publish and so on I
looked at the source code of the eight I
also created a bunch of tools that
allowed me to verify some of these
assumptions and kind of see like you
know what slow what makes Coast still
slow what's fast and so on what improved
and this we'll look at today so and
first of all we'll have a little
overview of the new compiler pipeline
like kind of looking at their parts in a
high level and then we try to understand
like why is it faster what did they
actually do there those crankshaft
already was really fast like what what
did they do to make it even faster and
then we're gonna look at that what
language features are supported and by
supported that don't only mean like what
language features you can use but also
which language features of running it at
a good performance and finally we want
to look at okay once then what does it
mean to put my JavaScript right like
there is still need to worry for things
or do I not so the compiler pipeline is
basically split into three ports we have
the front end we have the optimization
layer and then we have the back end and
the clear separation is very important
cuz crankshaft basically has grown and
kind of you know kind of over time and
wasn't very hard to extend but now with
this clean separation new language
features can be added quicker and can be
optimized cooker and we're gonna look
into some of the
dito those two main components of this
pipeline is a ignition interpreter and
the turbofan optimizing compiler and the
ignition interpreter already runs
optimize attribute code that means it
already events rhythm optimal
optimization as Bikol and that's
actually really important in crankshaft
days the VA team was very much focused
on making the optimized code run really
fast and they were mainly focusing on
that they also wanted to hit certain
benchmarks to make sure that v8
performed fast and these benchmarks and
other browser engines but it turns out
that for webpages it's actually more
important that the ignition or the byte
code in general went fast quickly
because you load the page you don't have
time to start optimizing a code now it
needs to run immediately it needs to run
a decent speed and actually in some
cases the optimization kind of had
actually a bad effect because there's
overhead right and if you have to
optimize very quickly because a bytecode
is very slow that means you you also
have to do pinoys more because you your
assumptions are violated more often so
basically why the interpreter is running
a bytecode it also collects information
about how you actually call in your
functions are you calling it with
integers are you calling with strings
and that information is stored in inline
caches basically in feedback vectors
which is basically kind of like an array
with different slots in there and that
information is later used by the
optimizing compiler to generate the code
that is exactly tailored to the use case
that you have so in the past we've
easily had a huge performance Clips
right and the reason was again because
the bytecode was much much slower than
the optimized code and so what could
happen is your code runs really fast and
then you changed something that doesn't
seem that significant to you but then
you would trip up crankshaft and
crankshaft says ok I know I can't
optimize this function and so we had
fall off the performance cliff so then
when you fell off Danya basically ran by
code and that bike code was super slow
compared to the optimized code so your
performance characteristics were very
unpredictable we could would see
sometimes like
runs like a hundred times now with the
new york pipeline you still will hit fun
stuff a little bit it will still run a
little bit slower but it won't be quite
as much because they bite goat itself is
already pretty fast so that's that's a
big improvement so now let's look at the
optimizing compiler so here's a summary
crankshaft is fast - one fan is insanely
fast right so I know we're gonna look at
like how did they do that right I mean
there weren't really smart people are
working on Crenshaw how could they make
it even faster so let's look at an
optimizing compiler in general first so
basically an optimizing compiler works
together with the runtime profiler
basically one time profiler will
identify a function and say this
function is running a lot
could you please optimizes and then
basically it gives the inline caches
that we saw earlier - that optimizing
compiler and says here are the input
types that you need to consider and then
it generates code for these specific
cases and it basically speculates that
if you have been calling this functions
with integers in the past now in the
future you will also only call it
integers and that's why that code will
work and now let's look at what language
features are supported as some of you
may know that in crankshaft there were
certain language features that kind of
couldn't be optimized right so and those
were called optimization killers but
nowadays we don't feel worried about
this anymore
for instance integrators are totally
fine we can use four in four of you can
use a radar for H no longer an issue
that could also be optimized try-catch
no longer an issue
crankshaft when it saw a try-catch in
your function it would just like not
optimize at all due to shortcomings that
they couldn't easily fix in they're no
longer an issue promises when promises
were introduced to do crankshaft they
had a really hard time getting them to
be fast right
but with too often as I said they have
you know better separation so on they
couldn't they could optimize them better
and so promises are now also very fast
native forces now that's a particular
case function bind so
a function vine many of you will know
that that was kind of like an Illinois
like don't use function vine because
it's really really slow well why was it
so well in order to implement certain
parts that need to run fast they had to
recently be implemented in C++ and in
the case of function bind in order to
exit the function they were also part
they were implemented in JavaScript so
it had to kind of execute it had to
cross the boundaries I think it was
about four times and this crossing of
boundaries
actually it was slow also the node core
developers went into this and basically
had issues there because they would then
implement suppose particles they thought
it was slow in JavaScript then they
realized binary crossing is actually
causing issues they were implemented in
JavaScript by the way the clock is not
taking I don't know how much time I've
left now the new function bind is
totally different implementation and
it's super fast like they basically did
it totally different and no more
crossing of C++ and Java so boundaries
is occurring at all and now you're
wondering about how right you just told
us that in order to make things fast it
had to be in C++ did you implement or in
JavaScript that doesn't make any sense
well Midcoast assembly so courts of
assembler is basically something like
you could think of as pseudo assembly
it's kind of an intermediate
representation that Tobal friend
actually uses and v8 developers can
basically implement this intermediate
representation directly via a C++ API
and yesterday actually learned that
there's another dsl called torque that's
sitting on top of that which is even a
lot faster implementation of this kind
of sir assembly and since this ir
integrates really greatly with with the
rest of the vm like basically it knows c
calling conventions it can integrate
with the javascript ports there's no
more crossing of boundaries and
therefore a function y is no longer so
additionally course opsin includes a
bunch of features for instance type
checks on their level at compile time
and automating registers allocates the
registers for developer so you don't
have to do it anymore by hand in this
testable
so there's a bunch of things that we use
sources of bugs which again means that
the developers can innovate so much
faster to make things fast so now
there's a demo there all show we're
going to compare the function bind for
crankshaft and to offense so I already
start crankshaft and you'll know in a
second why and what is running you're
going to look at the code that I'm
actually scooting so we have a some
function that are curate with one basic
binding and have a resulting in the
airport function and then I'm running
this function in a tight loop called
loop ofin and so the crankshaft version
is basically just executing this with
node four to make sure I'm running
crankshaft and I'm tracing in line to
see if anything gets in line doesn't
seem like anything is getting in line
running this code and now about after 30
seconds it's done now let's look at the
turbofan version so we have similar
thing we have except we using no tent we
have 200 fan and I'm also tracing and
lining so let's run that real quick and
we can already see that something got in
line and it's only taking less than
three seconds so we have like a you know
speed-up of like 10 times and so we see
what happened here the sum function
actually did get in lined into right
which couldn't have been possible all
over the crankshaft before and obviously
that's a lot faster then it was running
before but even beyond that too often
can maximize their performance even more
so one thing it does is save notes so
you're wondering see of notes what is C
of notes well we're the node.js
conference right so maybe it has to do
with something that node maybe this is a
sea of notes no that's not the sea of
notes this is actually more the sea of
notes on the right there
so we see what happened in the past is
when we had a program we looked at the
operations easier operation would become
a node then we would kind of create a
control flow graph kind of seemed like
how this how these notes would be
executing and from that information the
compiler with an optimized and and then
spit out
the machine code well that changed to me
because now we're looking at the notes
itself and and just and how they depend
on each other we don't enforce the the
kind of the ordering of how others
execute yet and that gives the compiler
way more flexibility and as the saying
goes with great flexibility comes great
power right or something like that
so that enable C compiler to do way more
in Manish william optimizations and or
the optimizations that it applies that
up like a for can be more aggressive
more efficient so for instance there's
better redundant code elimination
because we can move the code more right
because we didn't have the ordering yet
and there are many more and there'll be
resources at the end if you're
interested in any of us and so when the
optimization is done that's then when
the control flow graph is generated
afterwards and then the code generated
from that so what does it mean for you
it can can you just let any JavaScript
now well if you write a genetic and
declarative JavaScript listen like I can
read it don't be super elegant don't
don't call me paste everything from
Stack Overflow that's like a one-liner
and and if you use good structures data
structures and algorithms you should be
fine
and that also goes for all language
features like even the ones that are
still being added as we saw like with
this new architecture the VA team can
much faster iterate to make things not
only you know not only edit but to also
make it fast so you shouldn't have to
worry anymore but there are some cases
we're really concerned about speed like
P performance so basically if you have
some code that once a lot like an
request and you are in a library or
something and it needs to be super fast
then you still can help be a to make
that happen for you so basically the the
code that it generates the smaller that
ends up being in the last case it has to
consider the faster will run so let's
talk a little about what that means so
monopole mega office and I'll explain
that right now so basically a function
is monomorphic if it takes obstructing
one input type so if I have a function
and I'm only passing in integers then
the function stays monomorphic
if I then go and pass it also like a
string and maybe something else it
becomes polymorphic because now that's
more than one
impertinent however polymorphic
functions almost they still optimize but
then they won't run as far as
monomorphic function amigo more fake is
when I pass a bunch of input types like
5 or more and in in most cases those
functions won't be optimized so what
you're saying okay well but what if my
function has to handle two kind of input
eyes like how do I do that well just get
another function and that handles that
other input type and now you have two
more and more for functions again so
let's look at a demo for that so so here
we have a program I'm just gonna run
this real quick because I don't want to
run out of time but basically it's like
we have two functions add Mauro and at
pulley and we basically the trick is
here that at Paulie make all at one time
with the string and the add mono we only
call with integers so we can actually
print the bytecode the ignition would
run and surprisingly enough it's the
exact same thing well that's because it
doesn't have to consider typeset it's
still like interpreting the by code so
that won't be the same what you also can
do that we can say let's print the
actual code with that too often will
generate so and then it will look
something like this
look at two files so basically this is
assembly we're looking right now and
here we have an mono and then here we
have the body size 231 we have at pulley
over here with a smaller body size but
but I just said it should be smaller
right and if it's one more thing the
function value should be smaller well
the thing is that if you look closer at
functional what am i doing
48 we can see that something says here
not in line whereas here the entire
operation got in line so the entire
operation is here and we can kind of see
like okay here's testing that it's
actually an integer and if it's not it
will bail out and does some cool bit
shift so kind of core smell is it's kind
of fun to look at this and and here we
can see that oh wow it's actually
calling out to an add function and so
the call itself movies know any slow and
the add function actually handles all
kind of types so this on the right here
the polymorphic version is in this
slower
we can also look at this a little with
the two laser which is what children are
pulled out of the 8 so basically right
now we went a v8 with certain flags to
give us information again if you're
interested make sure to go to the repo
and look at the tools that I haven't the
resources but basically I'm just going
to put the next to each other here and
so basically on the on the Left we have
the polymorphic version on the right we
have the monomorphic version so you can
see we're using J is AD right so we can
play with this a little bit this is a
fun tool that we can change some things
here and kind of show all the operations
and then zoom in on the ad and then here
we can see that we actually go into this
jazz add function there's a bunch of
stuff here going on and like the main
point I want to point out here is here
we can see that it's just checking that
these are integers then it doesn't
actually add right here and then it just
returns it and attacks it alright okay
so let's continue
apparently I'm running short and helps I
wanna run through so basically so you're
saying okay fine I know what it is now I
just post integers or strings
what about objects so wait so if you
could an object actually v8 will create
a map under the hood for you and
whatever looks the same to you might not
look the same to me so if you send the
same properties but you send them in a
different order that's not the same so
again I have some demo here I'm gonna
run through this because I was single
that I have five minutes even though
it's si okay so we have time to explain
all this but again this is all on in my
talks page so basically this is a way to
visualize some maps that are actually
created doing well this was running and
if you go to the very right here where
maybe I should show the code actually so
basically here we have a point and up
here are we creating a two-dimensional
point and then here we adding more
properties and in one case we're
assigning
Z first and here is running chief first
and here is an easy and then T so B's
the same properties but it's in a
different order and then we can actually
look over here that that we are indeed
having different Maps so basically here
X X Y then we have Z and when we assign
Z first we get this kind of map phase
and Chi first we get this kind of map so
we can see we have kind of different
maps with that's not a problem in itself
but now if you pass these objects to
some function they're actually
considered different types even though
to us it looks the same so I created a
tool the optic aide that allows us to
that allow us basically to look at this
like what's happening to our code like
what's me doing what's considered
polymorphic or whatever so we have a
some code to pay rent and we can see we
have a vector function add and subtract
and basically you can see that here
we're adding X Y Z X Y Z and subtracting
X Y Z X Y Z down here we're actually
adding but we're putting the Y first and
so that's a different map and this might
work for substract we're doing the same
thing and that's why you can see here
actually we have a problem and if you
click on that we can see that it was the
optimized because it encountered a map
that it didn't didn't account for and
then we can actually click on here and
we can see that in that case the
function became polymorphic so if we
turn on more details here we can see
that ad was actually optimized at 28
milliseconds it was in the optimize at
36 20 seconds but then reoptimize at 38
milliseconds and the end of us actually
optimized but it basically was now
bigger right but this is a tool that I
open-source and there will be
accompanying blog posts that were
published we can find this tool that
allows you to kind of inspect your code
for these kind of issues so so basically
what you want to make sure you want to
ensure that you have the same Maps well
how did you do that the safest way to do
that is have constructor functions right
instead of like assigning objects like
in line just have like a class or
something and then and then make sure in
the constructor you're always assigning
the all the properties even if you write
even if you sign into something that's 0
or whatever
just make sure that you sign them all
and then there will be in the same order
and you will have this thing that so
recommendations in general you want to
write a geometric declarative JavaScript
and focus on your application design
don't focus on the compiler that's not
your job then use appropriate data
structures and collections like maps and
sets so basically the more specific you
are about what you're doing the better
the compiler can help anyway so maps and
sets at this point are pretty much as
far as if you're using like just object
hashes but they may be faster in the
painting I don't know if they already
faster might might be busier the more
specific you are the better for game and
then avoid engine specific workarounds
like don't write anything anymore like
where you're wondering okay maybe if I
write it this way it's easier for the
compiler or something like that don't do
that instead if something is to optimize
for no particular reason like it doesn't
make sense to you file a bug with a v18
they'll try to fix it and then as I said
if you have really really hot code path
that's when you want to use monomorphic
functions but but the thing is you
should measure first right measure and
and say okay what's my performance and
then try to you know optimize something
and see that that actually made a
difference like first you should
identify that you actually have a
bottleneck don't just like why didn't
they go through your code and say I
think this thing should be monomorphic
because whatever like don't know that
just measure first and then see if you
can improve and as I said there are a
bunch of resources so here you got a
repo that I was going to actually open
this up that I have to where everyone
can kind of read about all these details
it's get a very pro v8 perf again there
will be I will tweet out a blog post
about kind of summarize whether it's
just in the talk and will have all these
things in there as well so there
basically I'm trying to have a living
document so it used to be crankshaft in
here and it basically took a lot of time
no saladna invested a bunch of time here
to update this to a to a friend and I
actually had the v8 team also come in
and help me out where I made mistakes
so it's a living document I try to keep
this up to date so if you're interested
in performance memory snapshots
profiling all these things that's all in
this repo and in this
probably most interested in the compiler
and the language feature document
related to the story and then there's a
the v8 code search which is pretty
awesome so if you actually won just week
for yourself how old this is implemented
there's a bait code search online that
they can just type in things and they
will find you know references in the
code it's pretty awesome
I use it a lot in order to to look into
things and then here's some tools so as
I said they wrote the optic ate which
basically shows you these optimizations
optimizations and so on and then tuple
as our map processor I actually just
pulled out from the maid repo kind of is
the v8 tools link goes there so
basically if you go to the v8 repo
there's a tools folder and they have a
bunch of like goodies hidden in there
that not many know about and basically I
just pulled those out and made them
installable with an NPM second random
and and they give you results and made
him a little easier to use and that is
all I want to show today thank you very
much
[Applause]